est ce que vous savez ce qu'on commun
tous les smartphones dans l'entrée du
milieu de gamme ou dans la fin d'entrée
de gamme est ce que ça vous parle ou pas
vous avez une idée pas d'idée mou je
vous laisse me le dire en commentaire je
compte cinq secondes à l'est alors je
vais vous le dire c'est la grosse
autonomie et c'est toujours là dessus
vous vraiment venir table et cibler les
constructeurs pour faire des smartphones
dans la fa d'entrée de gamme vous dès
l'entrée de gamme voire carrément dans
le début du milieu de gamme et c'est
exactement la même chose pour honore son
nouveau smartphone au nord d x lite ils
ont vraiment tabler sur une très grosse
autonomie
c'est toujours la même chose qu'on va
venir mettre en avant dans ce segment de
prix une belle autonomie deux jours
d'autonomie
un jour une autonomie un smartphone avec
une grosse sono mis une très grosse
batterie est il si vous avez une
batterie de 5 millions pérard on est
toujours dans la même idée ce qui va
souvent les différencier ça va être la
recharge est ce que vous avez une
recharge est suffisamment rapide parce
que pour venir charger de madrid 5
millions paire eur et bien vous vous en
douterez il faut soit s'armer de
patience soit avoir un bloc de charge
très rapide n'est compatible avec votre
smartphone ne mettait pas n'importe quel
blog de charges que celui qui est
compatible pour éviter les problèmes
on va jouer de telle manière au nord a
fabriqué son smartphone qu'est-ce qu'il
vous propose qu est ce qui est
intéressant qu'elles sont si les points
négatifs qu'elle peut mettre les points
bloquants
je vais tous vous détailler comme ça
vous saurez tout sur ce nouveau
smartphone de honor c'est le au nord d x
lite est juste avant de commencer
l'essai mavo précisé son tarif sur le
site de au nord il affiché à 259 euros
80 barré et nous affichons tarif de 199
euros 90 d'ailleurs ça vous intéresse
vous aimiez le lien en bas dans la
description et vous avez 30 euros de
remise immédiate et je crois que le
tarif de 199 euros 90 5 honte de cette
remise immédiate plus des cadeaux et
compagnies fassent une offre qui est
limitée dans le temps ça vous intéresse
ne fait plus le lien est en panne
mais avant toute chose si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas je vous invite à venir vous
abonner à la chaîne pour tout savoir sur
l'actuelle les smartphones les
nouveautés les bons usages
c'est très simple vous n'avez qu'à
cliquer sur le petit bouton situé juste
en dessous vous actionnez la cloche
comme ça vous serez notifié dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
très très cool soyons très clairs je
vous ai définit le segment tous marqués
notamment dire car l extraordinaire on
retrouve le boîte classique de au nord
de corée votre tiroir de cartes sim
juste ici à l'intérieur vous avez votre
blog de charge
vous avez votre chargeur on usb et de
l'autre côté ses deux parrains de
palinges et la côte est sérieuse baissé
donc c'est cool
un grand classique nous tenons à nous
intéresser ici c'est ce smartphone alors
la première chose qu'on voit autant
constant cantons prendre la main et
c'est vraiment ce qui va rappeler tout
de suite s'il se trouve un petit peu
lourd il fait 215 g on va retrouver au
dos un petit d'eau en plastique alors
moi j'aime bien ce côté là vers avec des
petits reflet ici c'est ce qu'on
appellera le vert émeraude et il existe
également en noir dans la couleur
midnight black vous le voyez à l'arrière
vous avez quatre capteurs photo on le
détail dans quelques instants sur la
tranche le bouton de volume plus le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qu'il est
les rouilles très rapidement et ça c'est
vraiment très très bien on a un grand
écran un écran tft c'est du lcd 6,7
pouces résolution de 1400 par 1080
pixels à 394 pixels par pouce alors tout
de suite at écran parce que venir lui
reproche je sais que je trouve qui tient
un petit peu sur le bleu comme on est
dans ce segment là d'un pas pouvoir
venir c'est un grand grand grand chose
vous allez pouvoir modifier affichage
des luminosités modifier votre
luminosité et vous avez le mode confort
d'été peuvent venir activé mais que je
trouve vraiment pas très très joli ça
car sans le marauder mais si vous êtes
plus bas et si vous le monter et bien
voilà c'est pas beau pas très agréable
on est ici un écran de 60 hertz un grand
classique dans ce segment de prix une
fois de plus sur le bas vous allez
trouver effectivement d'écouter votre
haut parleur mono aussi vous en douterez
pour noël recharger en usb sais je vous
ai déjà dit si un poc est plutôt sympa
et qu'on retrouve aussi toujours dans ce
segment de prix et bien c'est la prise
jack
le micro sur le côté ici vous avez un
tiroir de cartes sim avec double l'anoci
+4 micro sd je vous en parle dans
quelques instants il sur le dessus vous
avez le micro pour la réduction bruit
tout ce que vous retrouvez là c'est un
grand classique par rapport à ce que
vous retrouvez fois de plus sur les
smartphones dans ce segment de prix la
différence peut se faire d'un
constructeur à l'autre au niveau de la
résolution certains seront
hd plus certains en full hd + ça est un
peu le point de différence sinon dans
l'ensemble c'est sensiblement la même
chose qui peut aussi différencier un
constructeur alors comme ça on soit une
vision un peu globale au niveau de
l'univers du smartphone et bien c'est
l'emplacement du capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui est sis sur la tranche qui
trouve très facilement sa position qui
est très bien et qui vous évite de
l'avoir au dos certains constructeurs le
laisseront encore au dos bon une fois de
plus c'est un choix de fabricants ça
change pas grand chose au produit c'est
juste une question d'esthétique et de
praticité
mais là où au nord huawei font partie du
même groupe sont extrêmement différents
science et sur toute la partie
logicielle et si vous avez magic uag 3.1
basé sur un android 10 et bien
évidemment avec les web mobileme 6 l et
hns c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas les
services de google vous allez donc avoir
un smartphone qui va plus être dédiés à
des personnes qui sont connaisseuse des
personnes qui aiment venir gratouiller
et qui n'aiment pas les services google
et qui ne veulent pas google
on parle donc ici d'utilisateurs avertis
huawei et je voulais déjà dit depuis un
bon petit moment à développer une
alternative au ps store de google
puisqu'ils ne l'ont plus à cause de
l'embargo américain vous allez donc
retrouver ici
la galerie la galerie qui est un
catalogue d'applications qui cette offre
toujours plus et pour les applications
que vous ne trouverez pas dans la
galerie et bien vous avez pétales search
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose à savoir
lorsque vous venez d'acheter ce
smartphone parce que ne vous attendez
pas à voir votre catalogue
d'applications de google un peu standard
vous ne l'aurez pas tout se passe ici
dans la galerie la bière est comme vous
lisez ce un catalogue d'applications qui
se développe de plus en plus vous avez
dû tik tok vous avez dû coyot tiana
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et c'est
vraiment amené à se développer que vous
avez d'un côté effectivement apple avec
ios et avec son app store vous avez
google avec son père store et puis vous
avez maintenant huawei et son art
gallery et je vous le dis tout les
agressions vous ne trouverez pas ici
eh bien elles sont stockées ici vous
allez dans outils vous allez pouvoir les
trouver en tout cas ici elles sont pas
stockées vous allez pour finir les
trouver ici grâce à pétales search en
fait une petite recherche
je vous illustre avec une recherche
instagram instagram vous pouvez le
trouver ici et vous voyez que instagram
il est disponible à pkp ue vont pouvoir
venir télécharger le fichier applicatifs
c'est l'équivalent du point exe 1 sur
windows 7 une apk howey au nord met le
paquet pour vous aider à trouver toutes
vos applications préférées très
facilement dès lors que les développeurs
d'applications met à disposition les apk
si les apk ne sont pas disponibles
eh bien vous ne les aurais pas et pour
tous les services qui sont dépendants
des services google
eh bien vous n'irez pas très loin
notamment l'application youtube vous
n'aurez pas l'application youtube
directement dans votre smartphone vous
pourrez le regarder depuis votre
navigateur ou 110 petit hack des petites
astuces à connaître et une fois de plus
ce smartphone là et les smartphones
aujourd'hui de huawei et au nord qui
n'ont pas la licence google parce qu'il
en existe encore certains qui ont la
licence google
ceux qui n'ont pas la licence google il
faut vraiment venir connaître ces
points-là savoir si du coup c'est
contraignant pour nous aussi c'est
problématique
oui ou non d'ailleurs vous dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
côté performances on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme on est sur un
kirin 710 a assez honnête ça fait le taf
on ne va pas faire tourner les jeux les
plus performants dessus mais pour faire
tourner quand même pas mal de petits
jeux et bien ça fonctionnera sans aucun
problème vous avez ici ou 4 gigas de ram
avec 128 giga de stockage suffisamment
de de stockage donc ça c'est bien
et puis surtout vous avez une carte
microsd pour revenir l'augmenter jusqu'à
512 giga autant vous le dire on le
relâche n'importe quoi que vous avez
vraiment de quoi faire ici et comme je
vous le disais en début de vidéo ce qui
fait la force des smartphones dans ce
segment de prix eh bien c'est la très
grosse batterie et la belle autonomie
ici au nord n'a pas dérogé à la règle
vous avez une batterie de 5000 milly
ampère heures il y avait qu une batterie
de 5 millions perdre vous pouvez tenir
jusqu'à deux jours avec un usage modéré
une journée avec un usage vraiment un
peu costaud autant vous dire que vous
avez vraiment de quoi faire une journée
une mis en fonction ce que vous allez en
faire une fête plus d'ailleurs dit man
vous quels sont vos usages avec vos
smartphones est ce que vous êtes plus
sur une journée parce que vous
l'utilisez beaucoup ou alors deux jours
parce que vous êtes vraiment tranquille
ou marqué le mois en bas en commentaire
qu'est ce qui fait souvent la différence
et bien c'est la rapidité de recharge
ici on est là honorent super charge
c'est la recharge 22,5 watts vous vous
en douterez avec une batterie de 5000
millions paiera pour la recharge est de
0 à 100% il faut vous armer de patience
on dire à peu près une heure vingt 1h36
par contre j'ai besoin de le recharger
rapidement parce que vous n'avez plus
beaucoup de batteries et bien vous
brancher et andy
minutes un petit quart d'heure vous êtes
reparti pour un bon petit moment donc
y'a un côté un peu rassurant là dessus
entre poids qui est très important en
terme d'usagé c'est toute la partie
photo ici vous n'êtes pas moins de
quatre capteurs vous les voyez le tout
premier que vous avez ici de ce côté là
c'est un capteur macro de 2 mégapixels
une ouverture de f 2.4 en eau y si vous
êtes sur un ultra grand-angle 8
mégapixels f 2.4 juste en dessous c'est
votre grand capteur principal 48
mégapixels couvre f 1.8 et en dessous
c'est le capteur de profondeur de 2
mégapixels tout brève 2.4 tandis qu'à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de ses
filles de 8 mégapixels touvre f 2.0 une
fois de plus on est sur une
configuration qui est vraiment classique
dans ce segment de prix le capteur qui
vaincus plus intéressant vous en
douterez c'est votre 48 mégapixels qui
vous servira pas faire des photos un peu
plus standard les photos vous allez le
plus utilisé vous n'avez pas de tels
objectifs donc dès que vous allez venir
journée jusqu'à 1 une fois 6 maximum
et bien vous allez perdre en qualité le
foie de lure à peu près aussi c'est un
peu moyen je vous montre le résultat des
photos dans quelques instants
l'ultra grand temps que vous allez voir
c'est bien mais vous faut beaucoup de
lumière pour faire des photos de
bâtiments de groupes d'amis en extérieur
et vous avez moins de lumière ce sera
moins ça et puis les deux capteur de 2
mégapixels que ce soit pour la
profondeur ou pour la macro c'est plus
gadget
une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte aujourd'hui en tout
cas tout de suite un peu moins de 200
euros donc on va pas s'attendre à ce
qu'il fasse des merveilles comme on peut
le voir ici la gestion de la lumière est
pas extraordinaire
on a vraiment toute la zone d'ombré ici
niveau de l'arbre on voit pas grand
chose ça c'est un petit peu dommage
on voit par contre bien le ciel le
bâtiment bon ok voilà rien de bien
exceptionnel là dessus on continue avec
le très grand danger là on capte tout de
suite beaucoup plus de lumière et je
dirais que le truc qui est intéressant
avec l ultra grand-angle et bien c'est
qu'on n'a pas de déformation les
nouvelles corrections et c'est justement
de la déformation donc ça c'est plutôt
pas mal
on perd un peu en précision mais bon une
fois de plus on est sur un ultra grand
angle sur 1 ce matin pas très cher donc
rien de bien déconnant là dessus on se
rapproche avec le x 2 ont commandé son
capteur principal est bien notre soi
même pour la mission au niveau de la
gestion de la lumière et dès qu'on
s'approche charles x 600 on le voit
salissez traitement logiciel mais c'est
normal on fait ici exactement le même
exercice mais de l'autre côté on arrive
un peu plus à deviner un peu les arbres
mais c'est pas non plus extraordinaire
l'ultra grand temps je dois qu'à peu
près la même chose le x 2
et le fois ci ce qui n'est absolument
pas exploitables on continue ici sur ce
petit bosquet bon voilà ça fera à peu
près la sphère l'ultra grand temps il
sera plus saturés même une différence
entre les deux ans maurice assez rigolo
et dès qu'on se rapproche pas qu'avec le
x 2 on perd en précision et le x 6 sali
son niveau rien alors la macro je suis
pas très fan soit à une distance de 4 cm
je trouve qu'on ne voit pas globalement
grand chose c'est toujours leurs proches
volume d'affaires au niveau des photos
en macro là dessus c'est pas génial
génial
la caméra de sel fifres altaf mise à
part qu'on nage et une trousse qui est
absolument horrible il faut penser à
tort bien monsieur dreux et le mode
portrait des tours pas trop mal la
gestion de la lumière n'est pas
extraordinaire la peau et est assez
bizarre
la couleur de la peau y à pas contés
très très très naturel ondes un résultat
qui est assez approximatif mais sur ce
type au logis de photographe sur ce
smartphone là rien de bien surprenant au
nord de propose donc ici sa version du
smartphone d'entrée milieu de gamme ou
de fins de gamme de l'entrée de gamme
oui le truc on a ici du nfc tout
sympathique pas de certification
résistante à l'eau et à la poussière
une fois de plus dans ce segment de prix
c'est complètement normal et bien
évidemment là dessus pas de 5g un
smartphone qui au moment où je sens
cette vidéo total et 299 euros 90 une
fois de plus s'il vous intéresse pour
trouver le lien en bas dans la
description ce smartphone pour moi il se
destine à un public qui est assez jeune
toute façon c'est toujours la cible de
au nord ils viennent viser les millénium
il est pas mal je trouve
honnête il correspond à ce qu'on va
attendre d'un smartphone dans cette
gamme de prix maintenant ce qui m'a
vraiment faire la différence et ce qui
peut être soit bloquant soit très
motivant
c'est toute la question des applications
du catalogue d'applications comme je le
disais ici n'y a pas de service google
il n'y en a pas il n'y en aura jamais
vous avez les services de huawei est ce
que pour vous les services google sont
importants ou pas c'est vraiment ce
devenir motivé votre décision
quant à vous positionner sur ce
smartphone là sur ce je vous fais des
très gros bisous et je donne rendez vous
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer
par le tec ont beaucoup d'amour a très
vite
ciao ciao il prenait soin de vous sur
[Musique]
m